but you know i wanted to think about uh
i wanted to think about you know we sent
in we sent a lot of people to space
and they just sent two fellows to space
two i think white guys probably i don't
know um
you know how america is these days hey
we gotta get rid of these white dude
right if i can don't send us anywhere
but they just sent two white uh they
sent two guys from florida
into space and that right there is just
you know i don't understand why are we
going to space all the time
that we can't handle we we can't handle
[ __ ] here
you know two out of two out of seven
americans can't swim
and we out there getting in the deep end
of the of the galaxy
with no floaties on bro you see what
they send these dudes out there in
this thing like a damn 84 uh chevy
blazer sometimes a bit that the thing
they send these dudes out there
you know and i just don't understand
what we're doing
it's so lit like i'm not saying it's not
fun to think about what's out there but
i just all of my just sending people to
space
we send two dudes out of florida a
couple spring break addicts every time
down here in florida we blasting two bad
boys out there
it's like come on going to space
the moon that's the thing oh we walked
we had a couple fellas on the moon
dude being on the moon is kind of like
that guy that gets on your like at a
pool party who gets up on the roof of
the house
he's like come on look at me bro
you ain't doing much up there buddy
there ain't nothing up there for you man
and it seems like a cool idea he's
climbing up yeah yeah
yeah then he gets up there it's like man
there's no vending machines there
there's only the opportunity for real
failure
you know there's only you're going to
end up in the white section of world
star hip-hop videos daddy
i'm just saying man it's time to get
back to the roots
we got to focus on our own little space
that's going on here
that's what i need to do i know that man
i got to focus more on my own
i'm out here doing all of this well
you know letting my thoughts go off to
mars and do this
and that and that's good it's fun
but man i need to i want to get back to
the roots
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one ah